i had all these secondary characters in
my world and i took them all out
does every writer need to know how to
write a pilot yes
yes it is absolutely a necessary skill
because
it's how you it's your calling card to
get executives to be interested in you
to get sure runners to hire you most of
the time
except for those picky ones like me who
like to see a spec if you're breaking
into the business and it's ultimately
what you will be doing later in your
career because
once you reach that mid-level to upper
level point
your reps are going to want you to start
developing and developing is all about
writing pitch documents and then
hopefully selling a show and writing a
pilot so it is absolutely something
everyone should know how to do
and you know there are plenty of books
out there about how to do it
um i want to say i think cam miller has
a really good book about
writing a pilot um jen grisanti has all
kinds of great material about writing a
pilot
so you know there's resources out there
to help you figure out how to demystify
it a little bit but it's you know if you
if you love to tell stories it's just a
specific way of telling the story
how did you learn to write a pilot
i learned how to write a pilot first of
all by just being a huge student of
television i there was a time when uh my
friends charles murray and terence paul
winter would tease me mercilessly about
how i watched every show on television
and it used to be true it is no longer
true there's too many shows i can't do
it
but
i would sort of i have a list of pilots
that like when i was writing a new pilot
and i was like oh the tone doesn't feel
quite right if it was gritty i had a
list of pilots that i would go watch to
sort of get my brain in that
in that place not to take anything from
the pilot but just to have the tone in
my head of like right right right this
is what i'm going for
and then go back to work on mine so
studying existing pilots is incredibly
valuable
and it'll get you know give you some
guideposts for
how they did it what the pacing of those
pilots were you know different types of
pilots can have a different rhythm to
them if you're doing
a big like fantasy show and you have to
you know launch it in the pilot what
some shows put in that pilot's going to
be very different than if you're
launching an ensemble drama full of a
bunch of characters who work in a
hospital right the the specifics of what
you need in those pilots are very
different so i would study pilots like
the one you want to write
and get a feel for you know where they
put the act breaks if it's a show that
has act breaks
you should always be breaking your
stories with act breaks ps even if
you're not going to have them in your
script
even if it's a streaming show break it
with act breaks because it will keep you
with a nice ebb and flow of action and
emotion in your episode
unlike some shows that you watch on
streaming where nothing happens for like
37 minutes and then the last 10 minutes
everything happens
so give yourself that break write it
like you have to do a commercial break
and it'll really help you find some good
ups and downs in your storytelling
oh those lists of pilots in the
different sort of genre or or style that
that you wanted to sort of delve into
did they age out after a while did
things become too slow after maybe 10
years you know how as life is sped up i
would say no i think great pilots are
always great pilots you know some of the
ones that i still go back to like i tell
young writers who are asking me like
what pilot should i watch they should
always always always watch the pilot of
hill street blues which is the greatest
show in the history of television i will
fight anyone who tries to say otherwise
because every show that came after it
that people want to say is the greatest
show in the history of television only
exists because stephen bochko was able
to pull that pilot off
because
it's you know it changed the game in
terms of how television was made
um wise guy is one of the most amazing
tv pilots i always recommend it to
people um the miami vice pilot
crazy like you probably could not get
away with the miami vice pilot now
because the two main characters don't
meet each other for an hour
but it's still worth looking at because
the character work is so
really really like interesting and you
know so much about those people by the
end of that pilot it's kind of like wow
okay
um
homicide life on the street one of the
greatest pilots ever the character
introduction of frank pembelton
is one of the greatest character
introductions i've ever seen like you
know everything you will ever need to
know about frank pembelton from his
search for his car
everything you will ever need to know
so watching those really great
shows even if they're 10 20 30 years old
the work in them doesn't age out maybe
the pacing age is out maybe you know
because hill street blues was what 52
minutes and and episodes and now it's
you know 43 minutes so they're longer
they can linger more in some of the you
know
silences of the characters and things
the driving scene like people really
literally driving down roads and you're
like no nobody has time for that anymore
but the character work the dialogue work
the ideas in the shows the way they
execute things that never ages out great
pilots never age out in that way
what about watching bad pilots as
another way to teach yourself bad pilots
is also good i mean bad pilots is
subjective i think even more so than
great pilots because i think right you
could google like alan steppenwall
telling you what he thought the 10
greatest pilots were he probably differs
from me but like that's going to be a
solid list of pilots right
bad pilots
it kind of is about what was bad about
it right so i think that's an
interesting study like if you asked your
ten of your friends what was the worst
tv pilot you ever watched and then go
watch them
you could still learn like i think one
of the biggest mistakes that pilots make
is especially nowadays
the studios and the networks are like
more twists more twists more twists and
you're just exhausted by the end of the
pilot you're like i
k like i was done three three twists ago
i that was enough i didn't need the
other things look like give me those
later so it's too much happening in the
pilot right
and that's a battle right now because
that's what they're asking us to do but
it's too much sometimes just too much
you need to say it's too much it's
overwhelming story nobody's gonna want
to come back
um
sometimes it's about the focus being off
like
that whoever your lead character is
maybe it's casting maybe it's writing
who knows is is losing focus to another
character and so it feels a little all
over the place and it's like well why
didn't they fix that why didn't they
realize it right there's a lot of things
that can go wrong in a pilot
sometimes just the directing's bad and
you're like wow this was a really good
script it's like too bad they didn't
have a better director because it just
it feels flat and like not
good and you know they spent a ton of
money on it but it doesn't feel like it
you don't see it on screen
so
it's it's an interesting exercise to
sort of just make yourself think about
like what would i have done different
if it was my show
what questions does a writer need to be
asking themselves while they're writing
a pilot
i'd say first and foremost always be
clear on why you're writing it what
about it is interesting to you what
message are you trying to convey
why why is it need to exist because i
guarantee you if it's not a thing you've
already sold
when you go out to have conversations
about it people are going to be like so
why why did you write this pilot you're
going to get it so know why you're doing
it because it'll also keep you really
focused in the writing process
i i was working on a pilot once and i
had written the outline
and i had outlined two pilots at the
same time and chose to write another one
first so i came back to this one and was
like great now i'm going to write this
and as i was writing it
i just had this overwhelming sense of
like
now something's wrong something's wrong
and what i realized is having done so
many cop shows
usually
the secondary characters
you want to write for them in the
writer's room and the studio and the
network are like nobody cares nobody
cares too many like we're focused on
this
and so i had all these secondary
characters in my world and i took them
all out
because i was like
maybe later these characters could exist
but in this pilot nobody cares
and so
i had to then go back and weave in
really important story points that those
characters had once carried
because that information was still
important to my story but the characters
weren't
so
it was like right you're pulling focus
away from this really important
story that you're trying to tell about a
woman whose personal and professional
life has been upended by having these
other people in the mix
so because i knew she was the most
important thing to me in the story i was
able to be like something's wrong
something's wrong what is it and then i
finally figured it out
so you were having too much of these
ancillary characters steal sort of
screen time yes oh interesting yeah
still screen time and and more so than
screen time it's trying to steal
importance right because in a pilot
you want every character to pop a little
bit or it's why are they in there right
so suddenly you're trying to create
moments for all these sort of
second-tier characters
but i want all the moments to be with
like the four people i'm most invested
in who are all tied to my main character
so i was like we don't really need all
these i will wipe the decks clear
and then get all those moments of you
know and that script has gotten me so
many meetings and and you know so much
development opportunity because i did
that because i narrowed the focus
so why you're writing it's really
important i think who your audience is
if you're
writing a pilot
that feels very broadcast to you
let it be broadcast don't try to make it
you know well maybe it's also a cable
pilot though no sometimes it's fine for
a pilot to just feel like a broadcast
pilot
and sometimes you're going to write
something that's like grittier and a
little more
cutting edge and it's very clearly a
streaming pilot and that's fine write it
that way
it's a little it's hard when you write
things that are right down the middle
because then everyone's a little
confused by where it goes
like what what's your target for this
who are you thinking of so if you think
ahead of time like i have a pilot that i
wrote that is very specifically i wrote
it as an fx pilot because i wanted to
show that i could do that like
premium cable sort of feel right even
though fx is regular cable it's pretty
premium fair on that channel so i was
like i'm gonna do that if one pilot's
very specifically an hbo pilot
because i was like okay i can do this
it's not necessarily how i want most of
my shows to be but i can do this and
this show fits the mold so i'm gonna
write it
and then i have shows that are straight
broadcast or
more like
disney plessy kind of genre sort of
stuff it's
just sort of know in your head like
because again it's a question you're
going to get asked right if you write
that pilot and an exec's interested in
it or a producer is interested in it
they're going to say so where'd you see
this
so no
know where you see it as you're writing
it
and when if we use that example of the a
woman whose professional and personal
life or sort of upended
when they asked you why did you write
this what was your
what was my answer
it was i it was at a time when
several stories in the media and on
television quite frankly had coalesced
for me
in this idea of
women who had done hard things in their
lives being expected to be ashamed of it
women who maybe had done sex work or
done whatever
needing to feel shame and i rejected
that i was like no like these women
survived they did what they had to do to
stay alive and they are survivors and
they have built wonderful lives for
themselves and why should they have to
feel guilty about this thing that they
did
and so
everything about her story is a rebuttal
of that idea it is about a woman who
made some really really difficult
choices when she was young
and owns them and it's not like she's
proud of them and wants to flaunt them
all the time but she refuses to feel
shame about them